all in us hi we are itsy
hi i'm yeti hi guys i'm leah hi i'm
eugene
hi i'm ching hi i'm yuna we are here
with buzzfeed to take a quiz to find out
which member of
izzy is our best friend you can take the
quiz with us
by clicking the link in the description
box
which of this quality do you look for in
a friend
honestly high quality for me
and friendship because i don't think
that without honesty
is the relation can't be deeper or
longer that's true
and i think sense of humor is really
great and create an important point in
relationship but i choose honesty if
there's no honest deal we can
get to know each other right my pick is
honest
oh me too on everyone oh yeah
what's your favorite activity to do with
friends
go shopping go shopping go shopping yeah
what kind of pizza movie i'm good with
everything but horror
and for me i really like zombie movies
and to spread food together and you
could chat a lot while
like having food you could talk with
them like or have coffee
and it's coffee and cake if your friend
is having a bad day
yeah how do you cheer them up give them
a hug
yeah recently yuna gave us a warm hawk
you to you yeah yeah yeah i i remember
that i remember that
like like this like me too give them
give them a hug for me talk to them
about their
problems a little bit more realistic i
would say
talk to them about their problems too
because that's what we usually do
we normally talk a lot when we have like
uh something going on in our minds but
i would first approach them by giving
them a hug
how do your friends describe you
all right great hard working hard work
yes when i was 14
i was training so my friends
always told me you look super busy i'm a
hard worker
so hard work yeah i choose right right
right
because i'm not scared of taking risks
really really really
i thought really opposite of you i think
you're very
careful about all of that me too like
she
be careful of like hurting people's mind
yeah
so i felt the opposite yeah then how
about me
cheerful
friendship is your favorite all my
things gossip girl
i like it because i love gossip girl the
show
me too i was like i not only because i
love gossip girls
i really like their relationship of
claire and serena
i thought that um it would be really
nice if i had a friend like this
like they fight a lot in the show you
know but it's kind of reason
because they really like each other and
it's kind of like
they're sisters and they're like on top
of each other they know everything about
each other
so like they get jealous of each other
because they like each other too much
i will pick spongebob and peppa me too
you too yeah i really like spongebob
when i was childhood
i always watching this which role do you
have in your friend group
yeah the artist the artist artist
in this team i think i'm the prankster
i agree yeah i'm not sure between the
mom and the baby mom yeah
yeah it's really opposite but yeah
sometimes i want to be the baby and
sometimes i want to be the mom sometimes
she's
like a five years baby but yeah like
find me that's all
like this but sometimes she's like
really mom yeah but
i then a little bit uncle uncle
pick an itsy song to dance along to with
your friends
because they know well
i got yeah yeji hi
myself i got i got leonardo
i don't know i got tattoo too oh you
guys are like
[Music]
yoona would definitely be best friends
together you too would be the life of
every party
wow
you're both kind hearted you're a true
source of joy and comfort
for a lot of people when i got taehyung
you enchanted would be the best of
friends you both
as sweet as can be and are extremely
dedicated when it comes to friendship
that's very true you're very selective
when it comes to making new friends
she is she is shh
when it comes to friendship you're most
likely
the person that everyone comes to with
their
problems because they know that you will
always be there to give them
amazing advice and a warm heart
thank you buzzfeed be sure to check out
our new not shave
english version album yeah bye
you